all right we are live come to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 44
so another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
it's the 2017 ALP holiday season finale
we got a ton of pump up G to talk about
and be results
the latest Bungie weekly update the Xbox
party chat on Android and iOS to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it
so let's introduce those usual suspects
at the round table oh look who jumped in
the back door we got Marcos with the
Cognos my brother from another mother in
the house of the young wolf me Lord
addict how are you doing sir pretty good
out here in these streets so
enthusiastic you know we made swords and
[ __ ] don't need that I wouldn't be on
this podcast
whose fantastic man Star Wars oh man I I
know they're they're different opinions
on what was going on as not an you know
far left filthy uber casual I knew a
little bit about some ports I would say
this it was slower the beginning I
didn't really want to know where they
were going with it and then the moment
ray just go headfirst into the dark side
they just don't beyond ok let's load it
picked up flee I don't know what
diehards are pissed off at second I know
one particular scene yeah I would say
this you can't be mad the midi-chlorians
we have the excess oh the lord of combat
sports was irrelevant convictions it's
nothing less than that premium
experience
Oh beloved Lord Kings in a building
y'all how are you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic on this glorious Sunday the
last Sunday of the eleven a.m. again oh
oh so you know last night combat sports
I'm just gonna get to it we have Billy
Joe Saunders versus this trihard fool
that was talking all this mess and he
got his blood smack shout out to Billy
Joe Saunders is dead WBO belt and I go
up against somebody credible so you can
get beat lilulu is nothing thank you oh
yeah speaking of which sex ed did you
watch any UFC last night I miss it or
lost I'll put me because I heard on Fort
Lowell all right oh okay there so the
the top two matches uh we had um no
let's go with the meaning that first so
we had those Arthur's vs. Lawler
um and what was supposed to be like a
match up for the ages these two guys
animals and all those the Beast laws the
guy that does not ever quit Motown -
yeah and to be honest I have to say that
those angels at welterweight is a big
problem this guy gave me welterweight
and he he is wrecking dudes and I tell
you this right now it was competitive
like Lawler was always in the fight but
Lawler Lawler's has become so
one-dimensional that he just wants to
knock you out and sometimes that's to
his detriment um so those are doses like
honestly his cardio was ridiculous he
long hates them he outpaced on me out
attacked them you could tell Lola was
winded by the end of the five rounds and
like Wow be honest
it looks like it's once woodenly gets
back from his from his surgery this
should be a great fight I see this you
know dos Anjos looking better at this
weight then he did that he would who's
the featherweight champ what
yeah just came I said I remember him and
it was it now maybe above feather maybe
right above because I've never you
supposed to fight Connor at one point
people fight and then that never
happened he didn't make the wing in his
son's the map and I thought that yeah I
remember being a because he messed my
Marisa and I used to he destroy Pettis
yeah and so yeah I would to me that
that's that's a big step up for those on
those he's a problem that was away and
then the co-main event where the
knockout the knockout of the night
occurred who fights under alpha male he
came in and he fought number three
contender Ricardo Lamas like Lamas has
been around for a long time
never really able been able to get over
that hump to win that belt to pick up
that championship he's always been good
we've all kind of been on the cusp and
Josh Emmet just knocked him off that
kind of moves left hook to the tip of
the chin and Lamas went out he was out
before hitting with one of those he was
out before he hit the floor his hand
three times and thankfully Emmitt saw
that and didn't follow up with
ground-and-pound like there was no need
for he was out at home but yeah
everything the ref am like like over
either of us you know it is funny
because they always let them get that
extra were like we don't when I see them
yeah yeah I don't like their when they
give them the body body the body by
anybody to see your body why you know
thankfully that extra nice didn't go
down and that was pretty much it known
and we have you know have homes and
sidewalk coming up oh I can't wait to
see that's gonna be a big customer cuz
she's the suburbs a big girl
Holmes is gonna get knocked out but um
that's with it yeah you know what it is
at Kong Holmes has moved she has boxing
movement more type movement so it's it's
one of those things like cyborgs full
arsenal is gonna be put to test cuz
she's not gonna just be able to stand in
front of hunters wail away because
lollies like I'll he's not gonna be
there she's gonna move so look at that I
love when the participation a boom know
it of course Lord kognito here spreading
that gaming realness on the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so let's get into
what modes are playing this week let's
get to the the birthday Lord on this
boarding day what have you been playing
this week just pretty much Oh
getting that pub Cheatham chicken dinner
chicken get us go down no I've gotten to
top five like 15 times it feels like I
would get like snipe out of my chance to
get the chicken there is talking that is
tough I definitely don't you go into an
adjoint dude and Lord Soph what have we
been played on the switch just someone's
that'll blade like just little little by
little one was on the blade and on the
console side Assassin's Creed has my
soul as it always does when he was out
and some pub she definitely got some
[Laughter]
that's what may look like little worm
not King what have you been playing this
week Pub gee you know a full arsenal
destiny and draw a cactus myself Android
cactus
no it's Oh Forza I boy oh boy oh boy
there are 60 frames true 4k man you know
let me sleep okay television you know
you want to say have true 4k you don't
mind checking for television for that
that pup gee let me tell you what Sabra
did to so we got all the guns we are
wheel and I'm like oh I grab your stuff
oh we went in the house got everything I
put your stuff on let's go to school
alright this is how the Hustle goes we
get all our stuff we go get these cars
so he jumped in the back of my whip
because I had found a buddy I'm gonna
back the whip let's go we shot over I
found another buggy I'm like I hop in
your buggy I get my buggy and then we're
gonna get to the middle of the map we're
gonna clean it out and we're gonna sit
there can't wait for these dolls yeah
that sounds like it let's do that
alright so we're gonna do right I see it
was a house over here let's hop out the
whips and let's go this do you test
friendship so question can you can you
give people med packs if you have them
yes team ok so I didn't realize you
could do that and have any books that's
not more egregious than me hot monkeys
love it monkeys loving the most
egregious thing is going you know we
made it to for me a monkey in the middle
of the map and I had these dudes on the
press
in this household I'm sniping them I cuz
I know how to use the scope and
everything so I kill to do this in the
house it's full of them in the house
right I'm so focused on what's going on
behind me with my king I actually came
in second and he was like he was he was
watching me and telling me like who's
around and whatnot and then when I when
everything kind of closed in I only had
a pistol and I'm like in the middle of
this field with a pistol and this week
isn't it hasn't been a lot of switch
having been I've been actually more home
so I've been actually touching that pub
she also shot out the Loire Valley also
birthday shout-out to Louisville con who
shares the same birthday Lord addict I
keep forgetting it so shout out the Lord
Vallecano name we got some pub G getting
in it was fun there's some duels yo
playing with vile conical areas because
no shame like he's going to run he be
like now let them beef over here yeah
and let's go left and I'll be like I
like he is all about the
non-confrontation then coming in and
doing the hi-yah at the end with people
of business know what was funny is a I
was playing with Jansen and kids smooth
and they got like going over a ridge and
they're like okay I'm like dude he's
just like hey and I looked at the UH I
think I want this 8 was critically
played or that I just straight-up said
the most serious voice let's go let's
leave
you gotta be like that because it was he
got down to like the final like 12 or
something
the circles closing it and it's like he
I got he I was running people over when
I was getting into they fell out the
whip and got injured so he so I'm like
cool like so I'm seeing people getting
shot and I'm like part of me is I know
you're supposed to leave no man I gotta
go get if they do they wait for me to
get over there to put the reverb but I
see hi shad out the dead Beulah takes my
class we waited for Valley con to bleed
out I'm gonna get over there many
stories within stories like Lulu
so I'm rockin man I've been playing a
lot of Destin this week so I'm getting
my master work so I know we gonna talk
about that later have a lot of fun of
that and I'm shad also been playing uh
see a thieves I got in that uh-oh joint
you know saying unfortunately I'm gonna
stick in a but uh yeah the good with
that but I could say and I know the
terror the terror beta dropped out so I
gotta hit up Louis wat so he can educate
me on his PC mm oh that terror you know
I mean so I'm definitely trying to catch
that I'll probably the beginning this
week get in depth with that the Raph I
think it's 73 so this dude comes over
this week cuz I have a schedule to uh
clean my boiler you know to do a
maintenance check on my boiler so comes
through what I was I'm sitting on the
computer and I started playing a little
bit of cuphead and he was like oh you
play come playing it on live right now
you know because it's a cross play game
oh yeah what's the game would say I said
uh King David OTW said what no way your
mom you're my list I say what you want
my friends list we played together look
and he takes out his phone with the app
with the beta hat please let check it
out
I'm like wow that's a good thing to say
mildew day you know cursed out or
something he did that we be relative
means if you know xbox live and fish
playing so let's get to get these poll
results over with so last week's ILP
polls are in and the people have spoken
with Paris games week PSX in the games
awards now over as Microsoft need to
take a more aggressive approach for
their fan base outside of III the winner
at 65% in our threeway ILP poll is the
yes Microsoft needs a dedicated show and
coming in at second and our 30% was that
no III in Gamescom are enough group and
the shallow third percent place at 5 was
the day dog six teraflops is greater
before their flaps what the Lord this
birthday Lord anything about this next
Osho okay yeah they need their own show
hopefully you know you know kind of be
more quiet about what's coming in terms
of first party and you stuff like that
hopefully they just build enough to
portfolio and have stuff to talk about
so I would say yeah man you need that
you absolutely need that so only has
that and they've kind of fumbled the
ball a little bit in terms of what they
want that show to be Microsoft needs to
do that and they need more practice in
any sort of in this sort of environment
they're not very good
it might have dropped moments and I'm
like at creating excitement in the
community and not good at doing that and
they need more practice dude yeah I put
Sohn against them so he doesn't get at
that got the theatrics they know how to
sell it look King what do you feel think
I'm crazy on this but I feel this is
when they should take a book out of
Nintendo's direct scene and with with
directs so we can get those directs like
once a month or once every two months
and it's different content if they do a
whole show and the production value that
goes into a show they're gonna use that
sizzle reel throughout the year so don't
let that happen
I'll do a direct control the narrative
and that way you can have those mic drop
moments because you can test that with
other mentors before you do it so yeah I
think the directs will be a smart
money-saving way to do it and get the
information out to everybody and if your
crowd that you're trying to look to is
your own xbox crowd and not trying to
reach out to the filthy casuals I think
that's the way to go I think that's a
great idea looking because it's like
also one thing about the direct is such
a controlled environment right you get
to control the narrative it's on your
terms you know to me in this way you
don't have those Gamescom moments some
things short out you know they're all
the type of stuff like that so yeah I
agree with that I think that's a good
look and hopefully um next year they
actually get on that train you know
there's come on this stuff a little bit
more no doubt so we're gonna get into
these topics and Taji back in the news
once again it looks like they shifted
over 1 million copies on Xbox one within
48 hours now this is obviously they know
that we know that it's gonna continue to
receive enhancements there's gonna be
new content updates I believe on Brendan
green he came out he says right now
he knows it's a it's a little rough but
he's saying that he's gonna watch it off
and actually he's actually better than
he was a lot he's actually also made
some comments and reference to I
heat protection cuz we also know that
there's a lot of Battle Royale copycats
out there who he feels have cloned his
work directly like that he did it enough
so of course we already know who he's
talking about no doubt no doubt
it's what he said lord I gotta say so
this is there's no he feels to it they
cloned his work no doubt is there's
definitely some conscious work she did
so yeah what I want to get was to the
laws op she's a ton of pub Gino's going
on right now so I wanted to start with
first the 1 million in 48 hours sold and
then aren't crash and so uh let's start
off with Lord addict wouldn't feel about
this tremendous success that pub G's
having and then also your personal
impressions of the game I mean does
anyone really expect anything different
from pub G the game that sold like forty
million in eight months like did people
really think just because it was on PC
and it's coming to console did people
really think console players wasn't
gonna play this game like i did a planet
x but my last planet xbox one of the
people on there try to argue with me
saying that the difference between the
players are so vast that you know people
just weren't gonna pick up on this on
xbox and i'm like this is the console
all last gen and most of this gin is
referred to as the shooter box and you
meet its he'll be like the king shooters
out right now is it gonna sell on the
shooter box get out it yeah I mean you'd
ever like to look my next box are you
guys you know
shout out to grind my gears I heard
y'all going at it with the whole podcast
have we heard it yeah I mean listen I
mean it's one of those things I guess
maybe from an Xbox perspective you
haven't had seen such a you know influx
of success on a home I don't say
homegrown but an exclusive title right
you getting to see this like tremendous
tremendous success in the in the short
amount of time them and it is you know
I'm not gonna say it's surprising
because we knew pub G is popular it is
just like wow you get to see the impact
like 40 you get to see the 1 million or
48 but a loss of what you feel about all
this success the the million in 48 I was
a little surprising to me just because
of you know how much upward has been
about you know game preview and what
that means and people not wanting to buy
into that like not being willing to I
think pub G was that game that people
were like you know what regardless of
how I feel about this program I want to
see it I want to play you know and and
the numbers speak for it it's a thirty
dollar purchase or it's still in that
impulse range that you know it's not a
huge investment for all with the hope
that you it's gonna keep improving so
yeah I mean again like it's pub G its
sold you know it killed everything on
Steam this year the fact that it's the
only place on console you can play now
there's so many people who play console
only people on xbox like you're gonna
see the sales but I am like I'm really
surprised that just because the game
preview thing like II didn't really keep
people away from it by they just decided
happen and toofie and see what it was
and what either they loved it or they
did it I mean it it's like I said from
the start you know people want to go at
Microsoft for making these you know
wouldn't really call this game and
exclusive alike a time to list of yet
because I do feel like even if Microsoft
would have reached out to these people
if they could made the poor it would
still be on Xbox right now because uh
the preview program yeah let's say they
you know they have no secrets that
they've really worked with this company
trying to make sure this port runs as
good as possible because I do feel like
if Microsoft wouldn't have went over
there and help make port they pretty
much made their poor that this game
would not be in the state that it's in
it you know people they want to attack
it because of you know the you know how
it runs and I'm like it could have been
way worse for day one I'll get to that
we go get it we get it to the ruddy we
definitely get it today I would have
also get Lord Kiro and you know that the
early successful numbers and young just
as impressions in a game so far well the
DNA of the xbox if people have forgotten
as shooters so you know halo has huge
success in that
regarde and that's what the DNA started
and it spread from there we were just
holding down call of duty and gains of
that ilk so now that we have pub G come
through and it's a very infectious game
I purchased the game five times uh yeah
because you know I purchased my copy I
purchase Disney's copy and I had gifted
game gifting baby yeah
gifted it out you know a couple more
times and you know Lord sovereigns
trihard Lauren Kyte back to rob me of my
glorious gifting moment and you know
good thing that you know I found out
ahead of time because I was gifting as
soon as I was able to gift it because I
wanted everybody to get in as as early
as possible to touch the game as quickly
as possible have G know a good time then
it is a good time um so it dis surprised
not really I'm not really surprised that
the game did as good as it did what I'm
surprised that to be honest with you is
how come PlayStation exclusive titles
that are full-fledged titles don't sell
or a million copies for 48 hours yes
that's definitely there's definitely a
question you know cuz obviously okay it
mean if you look at it from the
perspective of you know Xbox Live like
when it comes to preview games I noticed
how so uh lower sovereign says something
about 3d games earlier like you know how
that stigmas around it and people don't
really touch it like let's be real here
like your commercials might sell your
game but what the number one thing
that's gonna sell your game is word of
mouth and this is literally the easiest
game to so do your friends it's thirty
dollars
it's glitchy as hell but you you're
gonna have a blast playing it like it's
not hard to sell this game to people
that's what happened to Friday the 13th
like word of mouth so that game I don't
think they did any advertising for that
game that's a good point I mean for me
it was one of those things I it still
was surprising to me
a lot of you like when I saw the news
like two days right Wow like it really
did it just showed me the impact of pub
G and I mean I knew it was this huge PC
phenomenon not saying that he wouldn't
translate over but again I'm like you
know what it's not really a full retail
releases game preview you know how you
know can it really do a shout-out to vex
by the Jay he's like halo halo halo no
we're talking about games exclusive the
Microsoft that generally not that are
outside of the halo gears Forza you know
mode so it's just like you know scene I
was like wow this is really hitting off
and as far as the game is sucked like
I'm gonna keep which I like you know
when I heard about the game and the
battle royal farm and I'm okay I can see
how that can be fun but he's one of
those things that I'm like you know it's
one of those that you come in with the
hate lines let me see if it really as
good as people saying it is like well
we're taking so many losses lately then
of course you thought the main exclusive
that we had that everybody was counting
on was gonna do okay and wasn't gonna do
great you know it's called the beatdown
mentality just same way PlayStation has
been beat down by us for years so you
know they always out there with the hate
and the tiki torches oh shout out to the
two pub G on a Playstation like again
just my initial impressions will we
going to get into how it runs and people
wanted to man all they had to do stream
that on Twitch put that ps4 controller
in the service but yeah like I was
saying like just the whole coming down
The Hunger Games you know saying when
your maze and you know I do like the
cabbage announce aspect trying to look
for the best gear aspect being
randomized and just that tension like
you know when you see somebody like you
kept that out you'll engage let me wait
until I really get to drop on someone
and when you both land and y'all both in
the house running for the gun plane with
two other people we had a fourth random
person and like I got real bad light
random drops throughout the whole match
and there towards the end I was sitting
there shoot a pistol the duh the random
had an eye of an m14 and he's just
bitter every shot that sounds like dude
this dude needs to stop this like if he
was if he can't shoot this gun that he
needs to go somewhere else it was like
we're never gonna get out of this aisle
behind this rock because I'm the only
one that's actually shoots though I took
the shotgun out and kill it and you get
somebody you just robbed him for all he
knew I finally got across but most I was
getting my little Daryl Dixon off on the
walking across and I'm like oh there's a
cross-border throw you trying to reload
damage the tension is wrong with nailing
your neck is it's around ya just so many
low fun moments been the vehicles and
stuff like that and it like I said just
that perfect mix up you got a scavenge
but then you add zones closing in so you
gotta keep moving and keep forcing
engagements and they've got the formula
you know I mean so now that we got that
out the way I want to get into what also
has been happening streets with pub G
and it's about game preview and
obviously how the game has been running
so we all know that fateful day lord
serve Lord King we fired up of G me like
right did we got to airplane jump
the Jets and was moving up you know two
and a half frames and they know we got
that so basically you know we know it's
we know it's a game preview game that we
new company but I want to get into the
discussion of you know what I'm seeing
going on on Twitter shout to Salim rush
hour Jane finds relly
shout out to UM rich a review tech you
know a lot of my peoples are going at it
right now a lot of them come it comes
down to you know the fact that it is yes
it's game preview but Microsoft did
charge for this game preview as well as
the fact that um shout to grind my gears
from our plan to xbox and you guys going
at it but he made a valid one valid
point as far as that you know this is
one of the few game preview games that
doesn't have a trial normally in game
preview games like you got that hour you
could check it out to dip your toe in
any work all right let me see if I can
commit to the project so to the Louis is
looking what's the chairman give it to
him you know new about you know is it
acceptable for the game to be running
the way it's running you know I'm saying
like optimize and also as far as like
the game preview you know because mark
our marks are kind of seemingly market
this as a triple-a title you know is it
acceptable for it to be launched in the
condition has more king
okay I'm gonna say this right and you
know I'm a proponent against game
previews like I'm gonna tell you I hate
it don't put it on don't give me that
game previews cuz I've my my explains
the game previews to such this they're
making any better you know this didn't
you know tell me that okay previews is
here now baby let's play all the broken
games we can play
no um the price is 29 bucks right so in
the fact that you said there's no trial
is no try okay yeah get on the ladie I'm
bro either you enter you out no dip your
toe in the water you want you want you
want this product you will taste this
product will you had to buy this product
and okay so if you don't like this
product that's your business if you
didn't look at the three disclaimers
coming in when you log in when you go to
press the button and when you get ready
launch the game and they tell you
preview program this game is not in the
truest form it's not in the true state
and it will be you know growing over
time I think there's a lot of people
that have a failure to read we have a
lot of in this community we have a lot
of illiterate gamers that don't read
that are happy and trying to get to the
game first instead of reading what's on
the screen um to you my friend you
played yourself to you you played
yourself don't said I would a tiki torch
if you can't read that's your damn
business
I read all right so get to the 11 frames
per second get to the anahata I have an
X so I feel sorry for you the ones with
the Xbox simples out in these streets um
I feel sorry for you guys because I know
it's bad and then the other guys with
the brick box Xbox the first choice the
720 boxes yeah the danger they said they
actually have a competitive advantage
over X users because they have less
stuff on screen and they just run around
with wire pixels wireframe guys
shout-out to the wireframes this is a
work around Oh Lord are sovereign and
Lord or kognito and Lord addict knows
this we know this
turn off your broadcasts and stop trying
to capture everything and stream
everything turned it off and you get a
solid 60 frame I mean 30 frames per
second on the X I don't know about the
other systems I don't have it but um on
X I was gonna solid 30 and it looked
beautiful from there on you know
animation is still wonky and but the fun
fact that there's no more fun than when
I was calling sinister Satan for the
things that he was doing it shot the
citizen shaft is a cream in the chat he
said I rather deal with preview and up G
than to get raped by Sony in the no
minutes hits it it wow yeah they go I
did
let me get Lord addict real quick
he was going at this also on our Xbox
what do you feel about that cold thing
with that you know lack of the trial and
you know is it acceptable for you to be
running in it state the way it is look
when it comes down to it it's like look
this is the game run well first off
let's let's attack the the trial is
there should be a trial yes because they
did state that there's there's there
gonna be a trial in every game to my
knowledge they never said when that
trial was gonna be you say you know what
I'm saying like I do think it'd have
been a trial on launch but at the same
time they were looking over the product
of the of the product they were looking
over the state of the product over over
the trial and I think they did that is
because they like look like every game
that they've launched in the trial and
the game preview that had a trial that
had an online service like this crashed
immediately right so they're like what
we're gonna do is we're going to go
ahead and we're going to not give you
the trial and launch so we can launch
the game without it crashing five
seconds into the first match because
that's the I gave it to you the sales
would be half what they are now if that
if that's what the case because I mean
what glass for what twenty minutes and
it was down for two days we'll remember
um what's that game called with uh the
calling it's same thing lasted for like
20 minutes down for two days because
they overburden the service completely
it and that's what happened so you know
I do think that there that should have
happened I you know as long as they
launched it semi down the road when the
game is pretty pretty stable that's fine
I think people need to realize that
sometimes this is a big product for
Microsoft they're gonna push it they're
going to you know do stuff that's out of
the norm to make sure this game does
what it's supposed to got you now shout
out the diamond D in the chat he says he
thinks game preview and early access
titles are ruining gaming he said
because triple-a studios and put our
games that are not fully baked um I want
to get into that I've also want to get
lured solve on this too as well as his
villain oh you know to state a PG where
it's at right now
you know and obviously you know game
preview stuff so wait with this
I think with the preview stuff it were
always gonna charge upfront for this
game without a without a demo period um
it's it's it's different from other
preview games and there's lots grated
try to get 60 from us to be completely
honest exactly a unit not quite sure had
your guys mentality so I could have to
job and still get paid but I think yeah
absolutely I mean to me it was all about
money
they were always gonna try to sell you
this game upfront and then give you a
trial period afterwards Bungie unlike a
lot of other game preview games is
already a known quantity it's already
you already know what you're gonna get
with it you already know the popularity
of it you're not gonna not you know ride
that wave and charge people for it so
that was always gonna happen and then
we're always gonna demo the game
afterwards when it was in a little bit
of a cleaner State yeah I mean you get
those people that are on the fence and
don't really know about it afterwards to
purchase the game so that was that's
that and in terms of what the game is
now and what it could be to all your
people from playing the game on PC for
the past year we get it we get it
regardless of the state the game is
running in yes it could be smoother Lord
King is correct if you turn off your DVR
functionality once you're on the ground
which is the important part of the game
forget about you know parachuting in
forget about the little lobby area once
you're on the ground is when the game's
important
it runs considerably smoother if you
turn off that DVR stuff I'm not a big
proponent of you know hacking your
systems make a deuced run better but
whatever nothing I definitely want to
share something to you guys like this is
the reason pub he is selling the way it
is go ahead and go ahead and share that
for everyone I gotta get this dude right
here to the right
yeah see him I see ya to the right he's
going up behind my my teammate Jansen
because I got behind him somehow so I've
sit here like
legitly just go in the games not running
like this and the gay in the real game
it's running like this because of [ __ ]
because of the stream so I just
literally behind it would just keep
inching he's shooting about I just shoot
twice I mean yeah and that's what a des
I said we get it that part of the game
no matter the game is is isn't good
enough condition where that aspect of
the game doesn't get lost you still have
so much fun with the game so it's one of
those things like if if you're in
especially with your friends sometimes
playing solo it can get you know a
little bored if you're camping somewhere
and you're just waiting for people to
come to you but when you're with your
friends something's always going on even
just the banter going back and forth
like the game that the appeal of the
game is there and that's why it's sold a
million copies in two days
hey this this is one of the only games
I've ever played that made camping fun
watch Americans a lot there was at the
very end where the circle was mad small
it was over two buildings so we knew
they were coming in our house eventually
so we got shut all the doors so they
wouldn't think no one's walked in there
and the moment they open that bathroom
door we just laid them as far as the fun
we get I guess what I want to go play
devil's advocate because obviously like
I said shout out to Sala Brava he's
going able to the draggy they going in
the issue what they're saying is and I
want to bring this back to the table is
that they're like because Microsoft is
marketing this as a console exclusive as
a triple-a title right dad as a consumer
even though it's in game preview that we
should demand more because of the state
that it's in because of how bad it
running you know people want to make it
that wave just because it's pub G if it
were any other game with a lesser name
or less a known name the status thing
wouldn't be as much of an issue
it's the punky thing and in the fact
that Microsoft when they said they said
it's coming and it's in game preview and
they didn't give details behind it they
just said it's a preview when everybody
expected that because they were giving
them the White Glove treatment
treating it at a first-party kind of
exclusive then it was gonna be in a more
refined snake all right did they expect
this game to come out on xbox look like
uncharted or something
now the thing is now remember again in
the defense of the people who are going
in remember Microsoft came out was like
yo we got the coalition guys in our name
did we giving it the white gloves you
know say it's gonna be optimized so then
they kind of see this and launch was
kind of surprised when it's done the
coalition guys yes where's the cold air
with the cold did you use because if you
look at the game if you start digging
into the game you know there's a
keyboard functionality to the game right
when you like in the settings and stuff
like that shout the X button in chat the
trick marketing from the standpoint of
one now they're offering this as free to
pack in title with the Xbox one X to
finish if you go to any retail section
line you go to Walmart good stuff it
says Xbox one console exclusive they
have a big poster it's being marketed in
the same fashion that a triple-a xbox
game is you cannot deny it that's all I
brought I'm not justifying what's going
on you know what's funny
you got any of these marketing retailers
you go to you know the how they're
bundling it with the x4 I think it's
like two weeks or a week guess what's on
all of that marketing what's on it in
game preview oh of course
know your app see now that's where I
sighed back with you guys like where's
the romance card stuff said [ __ ] about
uh no man Scott for the moat and that
game came out people know you know I do
remember a lot of people going at I
can't remember that the name I mean like
you never even left Twitter because of
it so you know I do remember people
going at them but I
don't remember the internet exploding
like this
well because it's Microsoft people it's
$60 for that game it was gently false
advertised came a full game became a
full game last week right did you addict
didn't you say that you weren't checked
it out of someone somebody would just
check that game out recently
I picked this a recently I did not know
was been focused defense no mask I was a
complete game it was it was finished
maybe it was promised was the CLE game
with the highlight features in the game
completely weird out of it that they
hire a was horrid bro and I'm not saying
I see someone I see main foes saying it
got try and stop it I didn't say didn't
get trashed
to be fair I said it did get trashed but
I don't remember the internet blowing up
like this over I mean it's just that
show me themselves again they went into
it acting like the game was everything
they had promised until you know day one
and everybody's like where is this thing
where is this feature though was a
little Papa didn't know textures what
was up with that dope big trash because
no man Scott memory day was talking
about how again they sold all these
universes all these planets you name it
it was nobody
so they member they got destroyed no
notice his name notice you know I do
want to notice about these two entirely
scenarios like remember how quick Saudi
caved and blame the Saudis no man's sky
under the bus with the quickness
horrible no this is where stars the game
really they want to go back to that
because this is where I kind of do side
you know what you guys far as long as
looking you know as far as like
Microsoft has been very clear you know
about what the game preview is you know
pretty much as a fans wave out on the
preview
purchase work-in-progress digital titles
as especially participating the
development process
help us make Xbox one games the best
they can be so do you come in with that
disclaimer right you come in knowing
when you launch this thing this is not a
final product
you know once the game is a purchase you
entitled every update his game and then
the other thing about game preview that
I think it also is being missed is that
even with Arkwright I think when arcs
only release it wasn't like a $60
purchase the advantage of early access
are you getting in early we forgot a
cheaper
we got a cheaper this should have been a
$15 game before beta testing it for you
I do believe that you fail should be
cheaper than it than the third at least
at least 20 it should have been cheaper
because we are beta testing for you they
pay people legit money and jobs for that
job solutely know what I say if anybody
has a problem go to Microsoft and get
your money back shut up
fat no I enjoy playing the game but
let's be real here like if you if you
drop that game in preview it should be
cheaper now if you are lady if you are
if you are putting your product out
there to be dissect and to fix the game
obviously your minority in this episode
let's throw the minority 45 45 let's see
the number today you purchase right you
got damn right if you don't like it get
out whiney - that is whining I pay too
much for this I'm having such a great
time how much do you pay for a great
time for the plate
how about that you know in reference to
the whole thing is like look I get it
you know the thing is with the $30.00
there's a price point there's already
precedent set because like the other
game preview games were kind of the same
exact one when I picked up long dark it
was 30 on articles I believe was 30
whatever whatever so you you know that
coming in for the most but I don't
necessarily have a problem with it with
it being thirty dollars you know I'm
saying that that's the price for
admission but I do agree with all King
in a sense that look you've got to
understand what the game preview is you
know saying Microsoft has made it very
clear what game you get that part
shouldn't be surprising if you're that
upset with the quality and I'm not
justifying the quality is not it's very
soupy some of the text is very in sixty
four ish you know I mean it's real crazy
to aiming is real crazy it hit detection
can be real crazy so if you feel that
strongly then definitely refund you know
and that's one thing that I like that
Microsoft has in place you can get that
digital refund you can you can take it
back you know kind of thing so lost off
I need you jump in on this as far as
that are whole quality in that I think
if you look at what Microsoft I maybe
they kind of painted himself into a
corner again kind of like what somebody
did with no man's sky were they back
this game back this big this big concept
and they made it into a bigger thing
that I think even developer of the game
care to make it and then they had they
had to try to live up to it so with this
I think Microsoft is sort of the fact
that they from the beginning gave the
impression that they're giving it this
white glove treatment and they promised
it this year they had to deliver on you
couldn't not after the year of the L and
canceling games casts on the scale
council have you had to deliver on this
regardless of what would they have
preferred launching it maybe in February
being a little more polished still in
game preview yeah absolutely I think
they would have preferred to do that
another thing is is that I can mentioned
that when you plug in the USB keyboard
this whole menu comes up right so
obviously it is a straight port and I
think if they really really wanted to
get the most out of this game they
should have just built it from the
ground up for the Xbox and and and kind
of addressed the issues that it had with
the original PC build when you just pour
it over the game you're porting over the
quirks you're porting over the problems
as well you have to deal with that so
again like B it's I don't know at the
end I don't know what people are
expecting the game to be ultimately when
it's when it's quote-unquote done but
according to untold isn't gonna be at
the level that it is are even on the PC
side so it's one of those things that I
think people have unfair expectations
based on what Microsoft sort of cortical
promised but at the same time Microsoft
sort of wipe their hands a bit
completely by the saying hey it's
preview and not giving any details about
what preview means but like I said like
hey you know what if you it's in preview
you know what preview means generally
right you know read like like King said
you got to read and make the decision
for yourself and then you know what the
consequences of that decision for me
there's the thirty dollars that I paid
for the fun that I've had with it no
matter how quirky and broken it is and
in certain instances is worth it is
worth the same way they you know PC
players at the beginning of 2017 when
they were like what the hell is this
game and it was broken and all kinds of
janky they still kept playing it right
so you know the fun factor is there and
I was there you can make a great point
also having reference that I totally
agree what you're saying I think that
they want Russia they told people that
this game was coming in 2017 it's hella
high water this thing is covered out
does it
I that's my gut feeling actor why it's
in the stated in its completely not
optimized let's call it for what right
keyboard you see the receipt setting you
don't say like Oh Lane Z we just gotta
get this thing out and I mean they knew
that deadline and they give you I don't
to say is the excuse but is it's more
like you can't say nothing game preview
going down when I went to download the
game and it says five gigs yeah these
are the same people like you know for
the most part I do agree with the whole
you know cats don't know better but we
got people with that follow gaming on
Twitter they knew this game was going to
be running like trash when it came out
on preview they not only went through I
saw the disclosure saying this game
isn't going to be a [ __ ]
representation of the final product not
once not twice but three times they
bought it because they wanted to play
and then they had the audacity after
they read all these disclosures they
knew what kind of state the game was
gonna be in they knew how it ran on PC
for what eight months then the state is
trash still like people don't make no
sense to me like these are the same
people that be trying to justify betas
it's a beta man like it's poster run
like that they're just testing the
servers and I'm like get outta here with
this not from what I hear we don't even
have the latest bill that's on Steam
yeah I mean I felt that was a red flag
with you when you plug a keyboard in and
you get the same PC UI of like what is
going on I mean if they really wanted to
make this that premium experience and
really really white-glove this game and
you build it from the ground up for Xbox
and then it's you know you optimize it
and work that way when you're just
moving it over I don't think at the end
of the day when this game is at one
point on state I still think you're
gonna have people pissed off with it no
to chat easy you made a good point too
and this is also one I want to get at is
that home he says does a disclosure
negate people's right to critique the
game not at all you can go in you know
saying but this
where I think sometimes the family lines
do get crossed it's it's like if you
hate it
fine if you feel that this is not worth
it refund your money but to sit there
and get upset at other people who are
actually having a ton of fun you know me
I draw the line with it because I've
seen people go I have people on Twitter
for saying oh you bought that trash it
doesn't work and I look like it's my
opinion like if they tell you I work for
a company that I be reading disclosures
every day you know why those disclosures
are they say you can't sue them you
could go on social media you can you
know you could do the pitch for thing
all you want because that's what it's
there for
but for people who act and like they
didn't expect this that's the people I'm
looking at you know what I noticed and
what I think these guys is looking for
likes and looking for to be explosive by
coming out negative to a game that has
such a positive praise towards it that
will only highlight your aspect red
dragon I mean you're a minimalist dude
and I've noticed everything that you
have done you have minimize you have
pushed down you have kicked Microsoft
you have then that's a lot but my
opinion of it but yeah what I say to
anybody that um has purchased the game
you played the game you tried the game
like anything in this life
if you purchased it you tried it you
don't like it the store has a policy
where you can return it return it and
just shut up about it that's the
ultimate purchasing power which your
wallet but you know don't get mad at me
or sovereign or attic for having fun
right real fun with this game and
whatever state it's in because I said it
I said it looks like a bloody mess but
it is the best bloody mess that I've
I've been playing let's just let's just
take a moment of silence to recognize
that what blue hole that what's
the company that make this blue hole
yeah seven billion that blue hole has
successfully making David play a preview
game this wasn't I'm the one sitting
there saying kill the program yeah
against the program though I mean listen
I don't want to get too crazy with the
red thing you know saying all I want to
settle this decide that I do here with
locking in which is like look you can't
get mad at people are enjoying their
purchase but the other side to it too is
I also make mad at people saying that
like you know we not allowed to
criticize it because it's game through
like you in on it but once you go in on
it then it's over what I'm seeing is the
consistent eight a day to day oh how
terrible is if you don't like it just be
done with it play something else like
why are you in someone else's you know
saying that's where I struggle with I
mean the gang came out when last Tuesday
that's what yeah you know it's the
seventy that's almost a week if people
are having fun in the numbers it they
let them rock out now the last thing
about pub jean-philippe over and I just
want to get off with the arm the whole
IP protection because obviously Brendan
Green is on the left set you know saying
with a couple of copycats out there he
lamented how publishers can take an idea
you know under the role on small and
then kind of call it their own we know
this is the Loki epic shot at fortnight
we know this you know saying but the
also thing is I want to bring his
attention at you know technically if you
look at his history he actually a pub G
awful bad that wasn't his idea
so whatever it is to the laws like what
do we feel Brendan green talking about
IP protection and cop cat look let me
let me start this way I very front on
the line of epic straight up
Jack fortnight's formula from pub G
there's no denying it they mean they
have everything you can think of they
have the Matt layout where you put a
marker on it
they had like it's so bad identical
like the only difference is the the
graphics in the building like that's
literally the only difference and I've
said here like they didn't even try to
change stuff around like it's like epic
in them and like had like it was like
epic was being petty they're all you
know it's like Calvin was running the
whole industry and he was like you know
what we need to you know you had two
other people talking to him like you
know what maybe we shouldn't be so up
front that we're jacking their performer
maybe something a little bit different
and cowboys like nah like forget it like
I want I want the bus going in there to
mimic their plane I want the map to look
alike I even want this circle to be
identical we want effort to know who's
daddy in a day it drops they drop to 50
versus 50 it's got a Betty
if epics got the resources and the
manpower to do that 50 on 50 so quickly
yeah or what went wearing high goes left
but how you rent the turn in a room here
you build him and turn off the lights
and the heat in this joint because you
ain't like how he was moving well I
don't understand you mimic this dude and
you copy this dude and of course like
you said he got his joint off a copying
but when your company go from your stock
price is $1.00 to seven billion dollars
is your worth you trying to hold on to
all your coins so you know shout out to
him to trying to protect his drink but
everybody's coming everybody's gonna
make a call because the stakes are just
higher like you said like his staking is
so much higher now that yeah you do have
to worry beforehand you know whoever
wants to copy a copy or whatever he
could have never imagined this game
we're gonna get this big how you have to
you have to
you gotta think about it like pub G is
not the first battle royale game to come
out it's just not it you know he didn't
originate this genre it's just the one
that stuck the most and it's the one
that's resonated the most with people
look get o matic
I know I don't know exactly what the
contract is when you you know agree to
use the done ro engine I think that's
what pub G is being ran on but I do know
that in a lot of a lot of corporations
if you use if you if you're an employee
of them which you know obviously they're
not employee of epic but I do know that
if you use their facilities in their
programs to do your own little project
they have the right to Jackie oh [ __ ] no
is I mean if that funny thing we can be
sure to float the level he's like if my
motto guy he because sonic ran and
jumped just like is not to say but I do
understand they said to me it is just
kind of like in gaming it's it's it's so
tough because you know that's how gaming
is like pretty much like whenever
there's a trend like remember when 5v1
was the trend Bobby won you know I'm
saying and there's always gonna be
copycats it's just one of those things
he like like loss offset with with this
guy branding and play unknown is just
that he he just hit the right formula
but this thing you know I mean just
catching like clarify this fire the
thing that was the sympathy vote I think
the most angry is if you look right now
Xbox most duty fortnight right like it's
not the fact that you know he stole his
that might upset him it's the fact that
they stole his formula and made their
shitty game into one of the most played
games on our platform
and that's the thing nobody plays bass
for at night anymore everybody plays
battle royal mode and and the arguments
that I've had I've heard people have
before tonight over pub G is that it's a
much more polished game
[Laughter]
Hey I mean it's these are valid points I
just thought it was interesting from our
respective to here you know Brendan
Green come out and talk about IP
protection I'm like wait a minute we're
like isn't your during a mod of what is
it armor wore its armor three it's an
arm yourself I just thought that was
ironic no armor like armor is its own
thing I guess it's more it's it's very
technical it's like a military shooter
and but again the premise behind it the
depth behind it it's all it's all core
to that you know I mean like this is so
he's the first one that took that engine
and made it into what G is about a royal
game with you know with the walls
closing in and stuff like that so he
added stuff to it absolutely but the did
the concept of battle royal no he didn't
create that he you know again it's just
one of those things where it's he's at a
point right now where it's in his best
interest to try to protect it as much as
possible but it's kind of like a
wildfire right now you can't really
can't it's gonna keep happening people
gonna keep doing it somebody better if
somebody betters your formula that's
when you may have to work mmm
for the nice breeze well you say let
Eric I said what's really hurting him is
for tonight is free yeah that's the
thing that is that is thing I will say
there's no like I was looking at the
numbers and engage pub G went live and
just to see a damage triple quadruple or
fortnight in that short period I was
like wow now it's gonna be interesting
to see you know continue does the
momentum keep up you know when did your
February hit now the stuff like that I
think what they need to do is they gotta
be consistent with the patch they got
him you know if they keep that and get
that thing playable distinct and really
take off and I agree with Lord King I
think this thing is perfect for the Xbox
ecosystem it's take a lot of people the
the thing with the like 49 versus it I
think a lot of people don't gravitate to
the fortnight because of the look of it
they don't like the cartoony feel of it
we like the gritty feel of it and we
said it when we play the first day it
didn't even even if in a Jenkins I'd
prefer to play that it's more of a
serious nature now shout out the phone
and they do got the building and you
know I'm saying
tower stuff like that these things they
can do but then I like pub G with the
vehicles we could just jump in the whip
we can get it you know and it's
definitely more gritty serious tone like
you know what it feels like to me it
feels like you know pop Gia's birthday
photo and fortnight in Saints Row mm you
know if you want that little cookie
little wonky little candy corn thing is
a place for that over there and if you
want that you know get down dirty do it
in the city grimy and gritty you get
down with the arm pub jeans and I'm
gonna pop G got that feel what's funny
you know if you use that comparison so
you know what blue only needs to do they
need to make that GTA 5 or the like
don't copy us bro you can't do it below
savage I said the main issue is that
epic introduced a direct competitor type
game while still being in charge of
engine improvements and refinement yeah
just comes on you know they M&M salute
alot because that's
imma be honest which are like normally I
don't get into like favorites maybe not
wanna play for at night until pub G came
because I'm like you know exactly what
st. Louis am saying it's like dickly you
know that's sheisty to do that when
you're working with it with whole knows
guys you know man I just that was up
again I saw a lot of people when it
first came out it was like oh they need
to sue them trust me if that man could
sue epic he'd have done it by now
like I really think it's like I said
everywhere I think epic did all that and
it was legal because they were using
their engine yeah they know we all pump
g'd out swimming we're good laws got
anything left to say on this
forget logs they will indeed be nice
bending all of us
you wanna recount as we look forward to
November for so long and looks like yeah
MPD numbers have come out and the MPD
has at least it's November record
PlayStation 4 the top seller in all
units so for the month of November while
the Xbox one earned the most in dollar
sales and Xbox so all the Lords were
incorrect nope you gotta give credit
where credit's due no one gave Sonia
Schott week up with at the Mario again
we all
with the new system you know how much
are they up to right now
how many months every year since 2013
no I think Microsoft like the first
month or the second month and they just
watch sting and then listen in the end
hit a cave Sony came in slow there's
been 48 months since the Xbox yes what
do you think would be a good number to
offset holiday sales like when it comes
to holiday so like the average you know
first the average beginning of year
would offset I'd say a million let's say
like a million cuz I feel like if you
say so nice on a million every month
that would offset when they do sell over
a million take you ok so you wear
hypothetically
saying they sold a million every month
okay right and that that is by far
ridiculous but let's say they sold a
million every month that's that's 48 so
are you meaning to tell me this Saudi is
sewed a million and Plus you know
obviously you know your holidays
sometimes I'll say 1.5 1.6 yeah that's
that's that's a parent but so they sold
over a million every month
this is launched and that so 48 million
mmm
so so you're on the theory that there's
something wrong with the numbers too low
numbers I just feel like that's that
that's a lot like since the switch has
come on this is when I know something's
dirty in the water they have one MPD's
every month rock and rock and rock and
wanna do so with September came we were
saying if it was good - it is September
Oh
Diddy rockin rockin rocket so you mean
to tell me in a month that they got the
Mary o the Black Friday and all this
other stuff cost the 15 million and
they've been winning every NPD correct
this is me Lord key there are two new
you so that means you know give or take
they so you know million a little bit
more every month so now so with that in
the breeding PlayStation and at least
is that right oh you mean to tell me no
your mother every month and how
Playstations got double B units for the
rest of the life I think switch fluids
why my gut was switch is that let's keep
it 100 they that nintendo's arrogance
with this month is that they didn't drop
their price they're three hundred three
hundred versus a 189 PlayStation slim
and stored in a $1.99 xbox when I see
some people in the what I am well aware
that there's a worldwide sells and
there's an angst all I'm saying is that
what what MPD's what they average Lee so
like every month I think every week they
seem like a hundred fifty to two hundred
thousand so you know that would be
around a million Justin NPDC you mean to
tell me that they soda nut million for
the rest of the world this is what I'm
saying like the table switch has been
averaging a million every month at a
price they didn't drop the price and
Sony's been losing to them so let's say
Sony's miss selling 700,000 every month
at their price and they cut the price
down
they blew past these do they was just
waiting for the price drop I'm not
saying that you know they didn't a
hundred percent chance all I'm saying is
it's a little fishy everybody's pointing
to then all of a sudden they come from
behind
and they would have had to assert about
1.5 million units a month since launch
no brat please bring us back down to
earth this is like a meeting of the
building Berg's it's like the Illuminati
is going on reasoning some
level-headedness in the room love that
someone hit home with Nintendo I think
it was you Cognito that it was look
thing because they didn't drop the price
or offer any sexy bundles for the muffin
November it's I don't think it's any
surprise they do I do want to state that
um making war right the switch is gonna
lose so let's continue
yeah so I look Black Friday and that
this time of the year everyone's looking
for deals so it's no surprise Microsoft
and and Sony ran with it I'm not
surprised you know and when when Sony
came out said this is their best Black
Friday ever I was like whoa that was a
statement within itself
I'm willing to bet that I think
Microsoft and Sony are probably much
closer than probably what people
absolutely would realize and actually
you guys are talking about worldwide
numbers in did you ask North America
it's not a two to one ratio it's not it
is war why it's much closer you know I
do I do want to state that you bring
that up Brad you know for the past like
16 months every time someone talks about
Xboxes sells then then people these
people really may think that Microsoft
hasn't pushed 5 million because every
time I talk about Xbox oh well there's
still like 30 million cells I was like I
think there are any work because I
personally think Microsoft has passed
the 40 million numbers I don't know if
they're at 50 I mean you know EA he's
already a and some other developers I've
said it's 2 to 1 so if you're looking at
2 to 1 you're probably looking at 35
maybe close to 40 lakh why can't we
Microsoft just may have 35 this is the
thing I always tell people like like
it's not that Microsoft as a console the
Xbox isn't isn't it's not that it's
selling bad it's just that Sony is
selling astronomically well it don't
smell right when you gotta look at the
test and it don't smell right like you
here's what the chat is say the chat is
like but how come if they don't smell
then why's Microsoft be the one not
disclosing units because at the while
it's embarrassing we're not waiting I
don't want you all the thing that I
think that Microsoft is beating these
dudes on a one-up on all nice with these
dudes know they women in order for Sony
they had to sell over 1.75 million units
1 million or they know there's my slide
again if you look historically at months
like NPD's talked about this in March I
mean this past year like March and I
think February they were doing like
300,000 and that's like that's that's
typically like we got like a fraction of
that 1.7 so let's keep I'm saying is
though is that there's like 1.3 million
in the rest of the world well yeah
that's that's that's possible that they
could do 1.3
I mean units worldwide sales 20 you know
games release for November we know what
the system order was but obviously call
a duty back on top do much hey watch the
dude bro whatever boots on the ground
number one and surprisingly Star Wars
Battlefront it's still pretty impressive
considering we know it's not going to be
called to call duties what call do is
but for Star was to still be number two
with us yeah what let's get a lot of rap
one is because he's
he's guests right now has a PA look brat
what do you feel about that I agree with
what with sovereign was saying look we
we live in this bubble and we forget
that there's this this group of gamers
the casuals which ruin everything for us
they buy loot crate's you know it's and
let's not forget I mean no Star Wars of
the last Jedi just dropped so there's a
lot of that game is benefiting from all
the Star Wars hype Star Wars is in
everyone's minds being heavily marketed
right now you can't turn on the TV set
without seeing something star with you
ladies I'm not surprised by this battle
do you feel about this with them being a
new look but the gamers didn't win with
this game not selling or selling the
gamers war on the fact that they stock
went down 2.5 billion dollars so you
feel like the dammit pointing that to
the to the star coders you can is
interesting I definitely was definitely
my eyebrow raise when I saw that I'm
like okay you look at a chest and so I'm
also don't want to get into the whole
point obviously we talked about the
order of MPD but also as far as on Xbox
generating the most revenue at that
price point but that was still pretty
impressive you know a $500 system you
know who you know got that that the
revenue growing so Lord Lord own brat
what do you feel about that as far as
Xbox from the financial standpoint in
revenue I mean I think it's great it
shows here's the thing that it shows it
shows that people willing to buy new
hardware and that is a huge win for the
industry for gamers I mean $500 is $500
from and you know I'll be interested
they won't release they won't obviously
won't release the numbers but I'd be
interested to see how many units they
sold but yeah if anything else my
takeaway was that
people are spending money on hardware
and that is such a big boon for the
industry and we should be happy about it
because it's late and I definitely real
quick I know it's one of your assessment
I would like a sneaker Durant might be
coming so I wanted a that exclusive brat
pub gee Rick
yeah actually that happen okay yeah that
happened earlier and you know it's with
the Rancic if I'm feeling it I have to
go like I know you just got to go and
you know I got some heat from it from
people with chat
there was some other people that agree
with me at like I was just saying like
this like you know I understand I
been seeing people out there saying oh
you shouldn't complain if you know what
you were buying and I'm like you know
that's I understand that perspective but
you know you the point of early access
is to be critical or to provide import
or feedback right so that these
developers can make the best possible
product that we can all enjoy love
whatever right so you know my point was
look I understood that had issues and I
bought it understanding any issues I
just didn't realize how much the issues
would have rights to me and so and
that's what I was talking about I didn't
say that no one should go out and buy
that the game is not fun or that it's
unplayable but people were think took it
that way and I think people have a hard
time when you criticize things right and
and look there's nothing wrong with
being critical I don't subscribe to the
idea because you buy something and you
know now look if someone says and
advertises this to you that hey this car
doesn't work it won't start you buy it
that's on you I mean you bought a
product it doesn't work this is in crete
vehicles this is this is a situation you
are buying a product that works it's not
finished but it doesn't mean you can't
be critical of got you how the game
actually performs in game and how you
experience it some people are like you
know I'm ok with pop in I'm not okay pop
in I have a sixth beast console I
shouldn't be seeing trees magically and
Peter in front of me that's not I'm not
ok with that and because you want you
want the develop improve and you want
you you want to be allowed to be
critical without being attacked exactly
and I don't think it's fair to attack
people you know and and you know I'm not
again I'm not saying and I said some but
I'm not saying that I don't know me out
I know you want to know I mean I'm not
saying that you can't have fun with this
gamer that's not fun that it's not
people think that when you criticize
something that it means that it sucks
where they can't or then it's on Play
board that you can't have fun with it
no that's not that's not and that's not
what I was saying at all and the rant
but some people took it like that it was
it was interesting it was definitely an
interesting rant there was a lot of
different opinions about it you know be
money it was part of tikkun
bribe he's he's not buying it he thinks
he thinks early access is a sham
these are the hustle not just because of
pub G mhm
just jumping other games you basic you
baby people feel like they beta testing
that was my whole big stick about it I
thought that they were getting free
labor and I said I was against it and
yeah I'm a hypocrite huh shallow quick
and this is this is why I voice my
opinion my concerns about it I you know
I use I'm always Pro consume I always
think like you know what like our hobby
is not not expensive you know I don't
put my emotions into this I put my money
into it right mm-hmm
so you know I I want the best product
possible because we spent so much money
in this hobby and you think about it how
much money we've probably all invested
this console generation right absolutely
so one of my concerns in and not to
single out pub G but it's like you know
if we aren't critical if we can't be
critical what message are we sending to
the game developers right what's the
incentive if they have so if he sold as
he stole 20 million copies of this game
right at $29 already on PC do the math
think about how much money he's made o
taken absolutely yes to me it's like why
and someone someone brought up in the
and the branch at well you know they
never put it over to PC but you've made
all this money you you know coming the
Xbox just didn't happen this is this
isn't a new announcement let's let's put
together a team let's put together a
team in place that can at least get the
game I understand its preview but at
least get it where some of the things
are somewhat optimized like pop in or
you know how could at least somewhat
stabilize the frame rate I don't think
there's anything wrong saying that or
having that expectation even you know
jump in real quick Brad because yeah
we're talking about in and what we
talked about the second team is was that
you know under no circumstance
definitely like this thing in our
opinion you know need Microsoft felt
that they had get this game out you know
the way it's been
it the way I mean Dave commits me that
yes it was coming out but I think the
shield that they're using is gain
preview right so this way they try to
say like well we told you is game
preview you're saying but at the same
time we've seen how unoptimized is it is
really soon it's rooting the controls
and stuff
I think the way they're looking at it is
get it out on Xbox as far as marks
nervous get it out all course will
choose the backlash later right as long
as it those sales in and we've seen what
the sales have done we have seen $48
million
it was just like now that they've got it
out there I think they were willing to
take the negative backlash just for what
that title can do I'm not extended but
you at the mindset of why I think things
are the way they are no I grew that and
that was that was kind of like my point
- I've just I think I was kind of
surprised how like some people thought I
was like [ __ ] on Microsoft I'm like
no I'm not [ __ ] on them like I
actually I think I think them putting it
out and and releasing it on retails
genius you cash a make that money a
Shannon yeah it's all a big thing but
like I do agree with your main point
which is like you saying you know we can
still be allowed to be critical of it
you know and also I want to defend had a
concave or the other flip side to is if
people are so disgusted with it return
you can refund it you can read it you
can say you can't refund the free one
that you get when you buy a Microsoft at
1x that Microsoft decided you know let's
give it to free to those people for the
holiday season that have the new Xbox
one X system they don't have to do that
you child a media he'd been going in
easy this is why he doesn't want access
and game preview titles because when you
buy it it's no guarantee that the game
will ever be finished that is true so
don't purchase it and actually I think
the screen title says your games still
in preview some of these some of the
issues may be fixed mm-hmm it says make
yes three of those disclaimers you know
before you actually get into the game
shuttle to everybody that didn't
purchase to be fair though I don't think
that's a worry with pub G I think it's
in the best interest to finish this game
and you know whatever is we will see to
it
you were the people were like oh my god
ours and it had like more hours just
would M be a pop G so a Lord King a lot
of curse of Osiris news you want to talk
about anything you want to talk about
that culture almost guarantee me right
now listen listen addict you know as
much flack as I give you are you put in
enough hours inside destiny you know -
and destiny to have you straight yeah
and I value your opinion
um shout out the tag t4 we get it in
shout-out to channel 5 shout-out to X
bot
I was on our the next podcast last night
I had a great time over there shoutout
to X bar oh four four eight I mean he
rolled out the red carpet was the me and
the saltiest game what was dish out the
salty man we had such a good time there
um love having the conversation with
this dude he's a great game I want him
over here with X but remember I told you
I want you over here playing with me on
destiny to somebody gift them that game
of the dlc so we can get it in um I'll
tell you our killer character for you
yeah well you know it won't but attica
be there helping us run through these
dogs bet that I don't have to kill the
character I have to see he got one deck
for you um
the curse of Osiris DLC is everything
that I hoped it to be the master works
and the stuff that they released on
Tuesday and they fixed everything as far
as they can right now anybody that's
having such a hard time with it I
understand your frustrations I share the
same frustrations but this is the only
developer and correct me if I'm wrong
cry on Friday Tuesday updates there's a
hot fix for your stuff that you cried
about in there and some other stuff that
you didn't even know what was going on I
was effecting somebody else in the
community they were around the clock
trying to fix things I have to attribute
it to Activision with Activision's our
corporate hand pushing Bungie in
directions that I don't think they
really want to go in um when it was with
Microsoft
none of these practices and things was
happening you know so you really have to
look at who's the parent company and
what is the parent company's track
record and what they're doing to the
developer if you get in bed with the
devil don't be mad when you sin you know
um so I've noticed that this has been
going on and I think Bungie truly
regrets getting in bed with the bag of
dough I really do you lay down with dogs
you come up with fleas and this is
what's going on and everybody put on
your flea collars because it's a game
that you really want to play I mean
listen I mean there's a lot of stuff
going on this week obviously um Bungie
dropped it this week at Bungie update
about update 1.1.1 any odd works there's
also the curse of Osiris web cam I know
you want to talk about that as a fans of
Osiris and stuff like that but I just
want to get into things one about mass
works actually started touching destiny
to back this week because this was the
update actually I was looking forward to
this is the update I wanted to see
massacres these are the type of grind
things that destiny one players loved
when you had that weapon you got to
reroll it and I really it's it it's in a
simplistic form right now but pretty
much when you get a let any legendary
can become a master so much you know you
can get a better devils or whatever and
not my first one was actually a better
devils and it had like a plus magazine
stat so I can hold more in the chamber
but to me was underrated about it is the
fact that in PvE it can generate orbs
not only for your teammate but for
yourself so that to me changed the game
because one of the major complaints
about destiny right now is that you
don't feel as powerful you don't get
your super as much the first attribute
that normally when you do your super you
create orders for your teammates but
with these master work weapons you're
generating orbs not only for your
teammates but you can use them for
yourself for some players I can play
solo content and multi kills with my but
better Devils and then boom generating
orbs food got my suit bring it and it
just kind of made it fun again like I
think that's one thing that was lost
they were so worried about casual izing
destiny and you know balancing things
from my eSport perspective if they'd
lost track of what made destiny fun
right getting your super feeling like
this powerful Guardian and I think mash
works is the right track and I want to
see more of and I know they're gonna
keep going on with that now on the flip
side they also announced the uh the
Destiny full of Osiris conch which I
know Lord King is hype about
he's a big kind of a guy we get to learn
mop in in the dawning is coming now my
only negative I think the timing is a
little wrong this is not the time I feel
that they should be about seeing comic
books outside of the game when people
feel that that should have been in the
game
it's far east or it almost feels like
grimoire part 2 but don't get me wrong
I'm a car guy looking I know you want
jumping game I think they're reaching
out across the board's like you know
like Star Wars has comic books and those
comic books is really nice I think is a
different medium for us to expand our
entertainment book um if you want to
consume the product in any form now
you're able you know it takes a webisode
someplace and you know sit down and read
it you don't have to you know have a
controlling your hand I think it expands
on the lore and it makes it more
accessible for anybody that's into comic
books and then maybe you're into that
comic book and you say oh man this is a
game and get into the game that way this
is another gateway in feel you on that
don't get me wrong I think the gesture
is cool can I get a kiosk in the tower
whack-ass it I could do it in the game
that's all of em no more great story but
yo but turn it yeah he's chapter 5 in I
don't want to turn the chapter 5 in the
group I wanted to see it in the game
will give me some city especially not
especially not about some content you
just drop just announced it the DLC came
up and then they got the lead story team
guy on the comic we are we actually call
it must be the season finale because we
actually give it our Activision a whole
bunch of crap
this come me look Brett later learn egg
first alright what do you feel about
this these announcements are have you
even been touching destiny to it all
this is what I haven't I haven't got
back on a destiny since I finished the
massage DLC but I do like the that you
can generate orbs for yourself nothing
that's awesome
yeah I've always wanted like I always
always we're like you generate ores for
everyone else right mm-hmm
but you can't do it for yourself like
doesn't make any sense like why why
can't you do that so like why would you
have the lead writer work on atomic
working on you know storyline or new
content for the game yes
like I don't I don't like easy the only
guy you guys like you know better back
by Activision I mean easy the only guy
that can do this that's what I'm saying
I'm just like I don't get it I guess you
know I gave me shoes it's just a timing
I just like this was that time yeah I
think but I think it's cool that they're
offering you know other other avenues
ways to you know experience the Destiny
world I do enjoy that I think first
thing I won't I probably won't get the
comic book I think it's also webseries
you don't have to purchase it you can
actually it's a free web series comic as
well they are they offer that different
medium told it to view it gotcha gotcha
yeah no I think that's cool I think it's
it's like I get it I was I was one of
the few that actually didn't mind the
grimoire cards I like that because they
gave me insight into the game I know
people like didn't like the grimoire I
know the Lord had it we know you've been
away from destiny but as I look at the
most games played
guess who shot from number 22 number 6
any of this get you to play master works
none of this stuff interests you or
where you're at right now you we're
still on strike
are we on destiny to strength what are
we doing with it I plead the fifth
what do you need to see for them or is
it just it's just too little too late at
this pull out of that raid and their
thing that I'm dirty and we got to
finish the boss betrayal ARP session
with Lord Anakin destiny where we get to
talk and I say here's the key to the
basement so you did you didn't like at
all like the rain at all
I love but it's no fun mmm so until you
get out of the Leviathan then you mmm
so this is not enough for you to be
running consistently whatever they do
for this next like let's be real here
like it the raid was cool it was floored
as hell it was fun well we did we we had
like how many I'd say we did we get to
the end boss in like an hour and a half
yeah let me talk we buy lower Cognito
not much and to your defense the light
level didn't even matter because
remember how many times was I die no not
at all
you would doing your thing as always
definitely maybe it's not like for
everybody you know I do put myself as
above average destiny player but still
like back in the old day when you did a
new right it don't matter how good you
were sometimes you legitly had you put a
hold on the raid and go go level up yeah
yeah and I missed that and I'm so glad
I'm
that feeling that look you're not you're
light levels not high enough to do the
rate like we shouldn't be in a man shut
up and let the laughs oh is that about
the about of light it's how you use it
if you try to play prestige with the 303
you got your body down this really we
got to do prestige officially but I
think I'm gonna wait because I think the
January update to show me what's why
would I do prestige to get something
that they fixed it now but they actually
have a bigger update in James with a
giving specific prestige or what stuff
that Lord addicts complaining about is
it weapons and armor like yes yes they
said they said they're giving activity
to make a mark what players feel that
the prestige activities are actually
worthwhile and they will have the
rewards that will match that so you
might want to wait for that January
update after the morning I look forward
to raids and I know when this night when
this this next write comes out it's
about um Rasputin all I know what's
gonna happen is see into the garage it
would have been different you know you
went through a little bit of the raid
and you fought cabal and they that's the
rest of the raid but I was up into the
last point of that get of that raid you
fought nothing book of all right that's
nothing that you say I definitely
enjoyed lost time sorry would you say
above X why is this right even an in an
expansion about vex like why didn't they
just like they could have just unlocked
that for the love I did at that point
well according to the lore when you jump
in on catalyst basically is saying that
he had this problem when the Leviathan
swallow
Nessus or whatever to plant it then that
X world is he could not get rid of this
being that was
inside so you're doing him a favor again
it's another one of these clean of your
worth but when he talks like he's still
being sarcastic this dude ain't worried
about no vex this D wants to mess with
you it's less about the vex some more
how you it's almost like the trials of
Calais I like the fact that they have
these these raids that have like a story
like eventually we're gonna fight Calais
and it better be epic because they made
me be on this damned Leviathan for a
year that's a good point of curiosity
how to end it because when I get to the
third rail a do we meet the real
catcalls like what happens we might walk
catalyst to be the size of a skyscraper
weekly update what do you feel about
Martin I I gotta say man like destiny
hardcore man Bungie has to be on a game
constantly updating because of how rabid
you guys are how much you play the game
out constantly you're playing a game I'm
not the game so like it'll get there you
get like I just don't think people
walking away from it being pissed off I
don't think it makes any sense because
it's gonna get there I feel like like
Cognito said like the masterwork stuff
this is all stuff they kind of appeals
to me because I'm I'm a big proponent of
RPG elements and action games like I
love it I love what they've done in this
asin's Creed you know all the stuff like
they did neo we're all like the crafting
and like in viewing weapons and fusing
weapons with other weapons
so this masterwork stuff is fantastic I
haven't got a chance to play it because
this ass is pre took over my life but
stuff that I love and I'm looking
forward to playing masterworks and
seeing you know having my weapons feel
like they're individual to me and
certainly that's what along and I'm
hoping it happens going forward with
armor like I don't know if I don't know
if this was the case in Destiny one that
they did have this stuff with armor but
I want the armor differ mortis
actually they just mentioned that -
because someone tweeted one of the devs
at Bungie and they saying they're loving
the master or assisting that this is the
right track and will it come the army
and they said they are definitely
looking at it so again this is something
I think these are baby steps in the
right direction who saw I'm what's I'm
not mechanic school square but I just
like and I want to give Lord King credit
because as much as we're a gone Bungie
Ragland Activision they are one of the
few devs that are more proactive with
changing them things for pretty quickly
and I think they don't get enough credit
in that respect so yes they came out the
gate you know kind of rough a lot of
microtransaction heavy stuff and I like
that they got exposed they got pulled
out on the carpet on it and now to me
the way this I look at this is that we
win as gamers when when the company
isn't it's Mia culpa phase you gotta
love them you know love you got a
welcome but yes do what I tell you do
I'm looking at look at most games played
an Xbox Live right now well we talked
had this same discussion maybe two three
because of two weeks ago destiny wasn't
even in the top 15 right now sitting at
number 6 you got Call of Duty fortnight
Grand Theft Auto Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six 2k and destiny - right back in the
mix so I get in depth get to what low
attic ones and I feel bad because you
know they're all gonna be hardcore like
em that it just burnt like you know I'm
not coming back I don't like which I did
but at the same time I think these are
the baby steps in the right to cry so
just rushing and as far as PvP I like
what they're doing there and I want to
see more things for PvP that was also
something I used to go Lord I think you
want to say something for more I just
want to state the Lord Cognito that's
like running the mile run graduation
numbers like are you mostly - did I be
in 280 to be a double six standing
ovation standing ovation your
four-year-old to know calculus give him
some time
one last quick topic just wanna run
through this real quick we know that the
Xbox party chat system is coming to end
already out on Android and iOS I was the
first to test it shout out to Mike
Ibarra retweeting the iron Lords and
giving us that love shut up you're Chris
Lord King in the building as my beta
testers I was on the road in the whip
had the brute of going head-to-head so I
had a look I saw the Lord King on I saw
him look young Chris in there playing
some destiny party chat was open so I
jumped in and it said connected and I'm
like Mic Check one two can y'all hear me
it was hilarious
like you know I'm like really really
really cool so I wanted to kind of bring
this to the to the Lord today as far as
the Xbox party check app and on just how
do we feel about that obviously resolve
in there get this thing going and then
on the flip side and a funny I kind of
wanted to talk about this in comparison
to our good friends grandfathered into
don't hit Microsoft oh please like up
with this nonsense if you don't have the
talent in your company to do this
software engineering efficiently why
don't you contact one of the best
software companies in the world and
that's wrong ending that with what do we
feel about looking how did you feel
Microsoft has always pushed our genre
forward
there have been a proponent of pushing
us into the future and having that
vision where others are lack of vision
and addition a narrow mindedness keeps
them stagnated in the bushes and until
it's safe for them to move forward
that's when they come out I look at the
other companies as campers and
Microsoft's all run-and-gun
mm I will say this to your point Lord
King I mean do we have evidence you know
Microsoft was the first to put a hard
drive in the system yes
you know Ethernet in the Box connect you
know as much as people hated it it was
revolutionary for its time you know
digital sales I mean for digital gaming
you know I was dis
bank controller the displacement of the
analog this was you these a valid point
I'm not trying to get fanboy I mean I
want to I think it's just one of those
things that sometimes Markov doesn't get
the credit it deserves for pushing
things what I think sometimes maybe I'm
not as a mistake but sometimes they're
just almost too ahead sometimes and then
tell you one more thing that game pass
it's it's more stuff than you really
realize that they're pushing it forward
with Sony tells you you can use our
streaming system play now and pay for
the stuff that you have already where
Microsoft takes the bold step to
reverse-engineer every last game for you
to play for free mm-hmm absolutely
backward compatibility to he'll still
with our guys Lucien everything's I mean
definitely
we cannot understate that loraq you say
sometime sorry one terabyte called so
minecraft edition what the controller
with the free game for $300 right now
Wow didn't realize that
Lord Lord rappin in loss saw if I want
to get you guys feeling on his xbox
party chat also Microsoft innovation
when you feel about that
you know we've um I say we but a lot of
the guys that that I was like I don't
know if a lot of you know but I was a
beta tester for Xbox Live's like mommy I
was there with you baby I had that
that's it yeah that's it you know the
head said that would break a lot and
this head you know had the t-shirt I
still had the t-shirt I remember playing
revolt for you know hours upon hours on
Xbox Live and but you know this is
something I think a lot of us have
wanted for a long time since we've had
cell phones the ability to
you know connect with our friends on
these devices these smartphones and I'm
excited for it I think it's going to the
one thing that Microsoft does very well
is they tend to know where the pucks
going and as I should I mean their
technology company so I think that they
take a lot of the experiences they have
as a software technology company they
apply that to to Xbox and I think they
do a really good job at creating
different ways for players to keep
engaged in in contact with one another
Xbox Xbox Live it voice chat is an
example of that I mean I remember when
they they got roasted for putting an
Ethernet port in the energy Xbox who was
but they were they were ahead of the
game in that regard they they knew who
where technology was going and they knew
that putting the Ethernet port would
allow them to do things that other
consoles wouldn't be able to do
specifically Xbox Live and I think this
is another another notch on their belt
and I think you guys are I don't think
they get enough credit for kind of
pushing the envelope forward in terms of
how we interact interact with each other
how we consume games game passes is game
passes by the way a glimpse of the
future of gaming yes and I think
Microsoft gives you glimpses um and I'm
telling you guys I I get I I get a lot
of [ __ ] for this but don't be surprised
to see Xbox as an app one day me and and
and and I and I and it may be more of a
Microsoft boom more kind of like a steam
like service and and I think they're
kind of laying the foundation for that
and I look there they we're you know as
consumers as you know techies I think
we're all probably techies here we are
all connected to the Internet these days
we all consume different forms of
entertainment through TVs through our
smartphones I just I just I've thought
for the longest time since Microsoft got
in the game this is where this thing's
that I mentioned and go
so my two cents absolutely
Lord sob what do you feel xbox quality
chat tap and just Microsoft innovations
no I mean I agree with the Lord's yeah
they've never really got any credit for
the innovations that they brought to the
to the industry is always some sort of
issue or not or what they did with the
Xbox one not to start a generation where
they kind of jump too far ahead and
trying to force the issue rather than
like what braaap said like give you
indications of where they think it's
going and throw feelers out there and
sort of give you little bits and pieces
of where they think things are going
they got a lot of crap for the hard
drive they got a lot of crap for the
Ethernet port and a lot of those
innovations are what we consider norms
in this day you know in gaming today so
yeah it doesn't surprise me if they can
continue to push the envelope in that
regard in terms of the chat app I think
it just it goes towards this their
mantra of sort of you lying they've been
really good about the Xbox community and
trying to find ways for the Xbox
community to be unified with you know
creating the Xbox app on PC to have
people you know join in that way and now
on your phones to be able to allow you
to to be in a party chat with your
friends when you're not near an Xbox is
fantastic and to me
I hope is that it's an indicator of
where they're going in terms of their
hardware like braaap said like their I
would not be surprised to see an Xbox
app because I think you know they're
they're going towards a services route
but I don't think that that means that
we're not gonna be seeing hardware from
them anymore I just think they're they
don't mind we're expanding where you
play your games and and I don't think
this is gonna stop them from making
hardware and if you choose to the plan
their hardware it's gonna be there but
for me this hopefully opens the door for
something portable down the line cuz I'm
with the switch I've learned that I
would love to have my games my core
games everywhere that I go like I don't
like leaving my xbox but I like leave my
place later by and I don't have the time
that I used to have
to play game so as much as I could focus
on the core games that I'm playing at
that moment I would love to be able to
do that which allows me that because
that is their core system I've sung with
these iterative consoles my hope is that
at some point their base console the low
to low tier console will become
something portable become something
portable that yeah and this is Mike's
box and for PlayStation I hope something
like this happens where they realize the
potential of having one of their core
consoles in their core family of
consoles be something that people could
take around with them and never exit the
ecosystem because that that's that's
what you want always want people engaged
so I hope this is something that's
indicating that that's where they go on
got a dog let Lord the birthday boy he's
got to go he's got a I know he's got it
a stop was birthday to get to so I had a
little quick shout out if we roll out
all you got the rope but thanks for the
come by I definitely will see you in the
new year on the ILP back again enjoyable
but um yeah just wrapping up like I said
I mean it was just one of the things I
totally went when prepping what king
even while King made a point with HDMI
pass-through you know just I was
thinking about achievements y'all what
about the gamertag I mean it's something
as simplistic as oh you're telling me
that's that was huge I really go rap
what about changing your gamertag but
you know what though that's an area
where Sony I mean you know sorta gets a
lot of praise but in terms of services
and features they are lacking big-time
slow there's no reason why we should be
able to change our PSN IDs I mean 2017
oh man listen when the hackers jump in
hackers is they want you to be exactly
where they want you to be so the hackers
gonna know that's the guy I hacked last
time so you can't change the name
that's to be desired as well but they
don't shout to us only as far as the
last on PSX they didn't make a a point
that they said by the next P instincts
they hope not to have this conversation
I believe was Greg Miller
come on kind of funny yeah it has to be
was like um you know so are we ever
gonna be able to change our game attack
next year what is this like ten years
later yeah yeah they need to do someone
with PSN now it's not a good value
service for is the same one that you
have with the PlayStation 2 isn't it Oh
pretty much out the way I look at it is
they've graduated online future wise to
stuff the 360 hat party chat season
because remember I believe what the ps3
you couldn't do convention party check
correct me if I'm wrong like it had to
be oh yeah yeah so they've definitely
improve but again we have to give credit
to what your credit servers for as
Microsoft and making those strides and
advancements but I definitely enjoyed
this party chat acting I thought it was
cool it's really cool yeah yeah I'm
excited I'm sad to see where they go
with this and the platform team keeps
engagement oh that's that's that's the
etske
engagement and you locked them yeah and
we got to remember something like weird
like like you know we we talk about
being old-school gamers you know
starting 30 years ago our expectations
in terms of how we experience content is
so much different then the expectations
of you know our children or you know
people that are that are you know
younger kids that are growing up now
because they have an expectation because
they have access to so much different
technology now and being connected on
the fly and and just having high levels
of engagement we didn't grow up like
that you know you wanted to talk to
someone you picked up the phone you know
or you know there was no cell phones you
know we didn't have any of that so you
know there used to experience stuff on
the fly
all these are like things that you know
Microsoft and and I think the genius
with Nintendo the switches
Nintendo can keep you in their ecosystem
anywhere you go as long as you have an
internet connection and that is really I
don't think people think about that
enough but that is brilliant
that's brilliant
you talk to your friends I know you talk
to your friends what I mean but you can
you could buy content I mean that's the
thing that's the that's the big I mean
you totally correct right it's one of
those things that I just wish that they
would just either I don't know if they
could just take a page from myself or
hire their engineer we didn't have this
great relationship with Minecraft right
so it's like khawaja it's like you
haven't charged for this service yet
right plus as far as switch you know
we've already seen in a beta what
Microsoft can do and they've ran laps
around the switch app it abated so it's
just like come on guys let's just get
this together outsource if you got do
what you got to do to just make that
online infrastructure have a friendless
be able to send messages have a party
chat say what is your ID number have to
be longer than security on my Twitter I
gave in we're gonna wrap this thing up
2017 holiday edition we got it all
pulled for outro so we're gonna get into
that last oh yes and it's gonna be with
the release of pop G on Xbox game
preview should consumers in general
expect higher quality from paid early
access games the question answers are a
yes paid game preview does not excuse
terrible quality be no a preview
disclaimer is given before you buy any
game preview game and see I don't care
pub G 1 million 48 hours baby gotta
shine I am Peter polls when it goes up
Lord rap thank you for coming in on 11
ow
for holiday end of media yeah you know I
just I just want to say I was listening
to you guys I realized it was you know
the end of the year and I was like I got
a job I got a jump in I always seriously
you guys probably my favorite podcast
and I and I and I run a podcast you know
so but the guys are great I really
appreciate it and really enjoy what you
guys are doing so just keep up the great
work thank you thank you so much thank
you for coming in thank again family
really appreciate you we love rap love
what you guys are doing and obviously
the new thing coming up with a little
crate radio or like this stuff so get
your plugs in man where can we find you
what's cooking yeah you could find me on
twitter at a drap underscore podcast and
you know you can find me on youtube but
basement radio arcade podcast we go live
every Wednesday night at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time off Eric Jackson
be money and mr. negative and yeah we
just not video games you know we have
guests on from the community and from
industry you know we've had David David
Jaffe on the podcast we got Ryan
McCaffrey we had the folks on from
supergiant games mmm
so it's yeah it's a good time and also
check out Luke chess radio I'm stay with
the saltiest gaming so I'll be love ya
all day digital so yeah yeah no they
bunch of good dudes and you know it's
it's cool because um you know we've all
been gaming for a long time and it's a
pre-recorded show it's got Jay puts a
lot of hard work into it so you know it
has a lot of production value which is
which is really cool that we've got a
lot of comments and people saying it
sounds like a like a radio show so know
what we it's really we just hit the
Twitter up we could find cuz you guys
already is prerecorded right so with you
that content can we get it so you if you
are you can get them on iTunes
you can also get it on YouTube as well
and if you want to give us a follow on
Twitter it's at Luke
radio he's gonna find us there so yeah
but you'll definitely find us on iTunes
and in YouTube so download rap coming
through in the season finale we
appreciate you man thank you well I
appreciate you guys thank you
absolutely shouting what Michael Oh
gonna chat sorry bro we just we finished
up the Destiny when Chad you came late
so just hit that rewind whenever soul
goes off we talked a lot about the
master works not like that stuff we got
you covered
Michael we gonna close this thing up
obviously the birthday boy is going to
his birthday thing we got the rest of
laws we won't do these outdoors laws saw
within the fact we'll find you and find
people can find me on xbox and PSN FBA
sovereign and on our Twitter Lord saw
ILP just a quick message to to all our
guests first and foremost guys Lord
Braff everybody who's been a guest on
the show this year thank you so much for
coming out and showing love and
supporting you guys you know you guys
are amazing I at the beginning of this I
think would have never thought I
consider myself part of this community
but this is an amazing community of
people and you know I surely appreciate
all the love you guys show us every time
you come on here so it's fantastic and
then to everybody who listens to our
show people in the chat you guys are
amazing I just want to wish everyone a
happy safe and blessed holiday season
whatever you celebrate um guys keep yeah
man keep keep gaming keep showing the
love man we we really appreciate it
the show has gotten to the point has
gotten because of you guys and the love
and the support you got show every
single week man so we truly appreciate
it so bless you guys and see you guys in
January absolutely much appreciate good
words wise word from Lord soft lord King
premium experience x-gamer 2017 in the
books fuss we can find people find you
you know I am so humbled at the the
reach out to to to go to other people's
shows and in the end and said being an
environment you know um I didn't know
that there was like two sides of the
community is this weirdo side where you
know the fighting and they they make
they have to manufacture beef and you
know always be controversial and say you
know f-bombs here and there and the
podcasts that I've been on my children
can listen to and I think that goes a
longer way we have intelligent
conversations shout-out to breath shut
up it to potentially perfect
shout out to um multiverse shout out to
the the next podcast I'm talking about
I've met so many youtubers and I am
humbled and and just to be in your
presence and have great conversations
you guys are amazing I thank you from
the bottom of my heart and out to every
person that tune in every subscriber if
you're a hater if your lover I love you
equally trust me I'm sorry that my PC
isn't up today that I couldn't you know
interact with you in a chat um that's
that's what happened that's why I was
absent from the chat today but trust me
um I do appreciate every last drop you
guys listen I was trying to do the shows
all the way through the holiday season
trust me oh look at me it was like
you're gonna take a grapple beyond to
the holiday season so if you want op
I'll be on your show holla at me I'll be
on that show sir just lie to my DMS and
hit me with that link brother yeah I
want to give a shout-out to everyone in
the chat obviously all the guests we had
this year Lord Ram's one of them has
been huge he's probably like uh he's up
there I think when anchorman it else was
up there top of them like most
appearances and I um fetus yeah there's
a rap you know he's fan but I'm shocked
everybody you know this is our work year
shot to the tick network man I'll hold
us down
double X
the motive for ticktock-tastic no ask me
no that's the fame you know everybody
really appreciates the support and all
the exact everyone I chose tremendous
love the ILP again this is our key and
it's just been really overwhelming just
to see how much the appreciation has
been there for us and that you guys
enjoying what we're doing we're gonna
try to continue to do more but I'm
bigger stuff in 2017 and 2018 so I'm
here the new time just to put that out
there we're gonna go back to 1 p.m. each
week so that's what's coming back
there'll be the first row so again
happy holidays you know I'm saying make
sure oh shout out the anchor may yes
game any community Awards tomorrow on
the multi-verse please please check that
out we got some good podcasting I love I
cast it definitely got nominated
I believe short pause gaming those are
great guys too and also my brothers all
four guys with quarters man love all
those podcasts so make sure you vote is
really the losers we all got nominated
so everyone's recognizing what we're
doing and what everyone else is doing so
check that our multiverse is gonna be
lit and is gonna hold that down it go
make sure you try like five extra votes
for ILP because we're holding for us to
win this will be on sale but yeah it's
gonna be really funny just really really
appreciate it and again Happy Holidays
man Merry Christmas and New Year's
that's going down everyone get get nice
and drunk and fed enjoy time with their
family and loved ones and all that good
stuff now and we are gonna end this
thing so anybody anything else to say
we're gonna wrap it up
yes Mac see you 18 peace peace